in their time a highly intelligent
space-faring race known as the protheans
were the dominant force
their influence would go on to shape the
galaxy and even the evolution of
entire species the prothean empire
reached heights that no other had
but this success also doomed it to
extinction
in the starless void between galaxies
known as darkspace awaited the reapers
as intelligent life flourished in the
milky way they lay dormant and when the
time came
they emerged to serve their function a
galaxy-wide harvesting of life that
would bring the cycle to an end
the protheans were many but when the
reapers appeared their defeat was swift
ironically the protheans greatest
strength became their most critical
vulnerability
but how and why did it all go wrong to
understand that you need to know the
protheans as a species
so settle in as we dig into the law of
one of mass effect's most
important races there's gonna be
spoilers for the entire mass effect
trilogy so beware if you're playing for
the first time
the protheans existed in a cycle 50 000
years before the one commander shepard
fights to preserve
although their empire was vast in the
cycle of evolution and dissolution
perpetuated by the reapers all traces of
previous life are usually wiped out
as a result little is known about the
protheans and often
much is falsely attributed to them like
most races prothean civilization and its
expansion
across the galaxy was enabled by the
work of species that predated it
after taking to the stars they
discovered the ruins of the inusinon
another race wiped from existence by the
reapers however the remnants of inusinon
existence gave the protheans what they
needed to understand the physics of mass
effect fields and
eventually create faster than light
travel this allowed them to spread their
reach farther
quicker at the core of prothean beliefs
is the cosmic imperative this is
explained by javik a prothean that is
discovered in stasis and brought into
shepherd's cycle to fight the reapers
protheans operated on the idea that the
strong flourished and the weak perished
their scientists deemed the cosmic
imperative as the only force in the
galaxy of consequence
in javik's own words extinction was said
to be the rule of law in the cosmos it
was the natural order of things with
this in mind the motivations and methods
behind the aggressive protein expansion
becomes clear as they traveled the
galaxy the protheans exerted their power
over other species and although some
tried to resist
none were successful such was the might
of the profian empire
those that fell before them had no
choice but to be assimilated and
over time disparate races and cultures
would conform
eventually coming to identify themselves
as prothean
the goal of this was twofold not only
did it allow protheans to expand their
influence and enact the cosmic
imperative doctrine but it also united
organics to face future threats from
synthetics
something that had also become a key
concern for the protheans
early on in its exploration of the
galaxy the protheans encountered a
machine artificial intelligence which
was hostile and posed a threat to them
eventually this resulted in the metacon
war the protheans won this battle and
to protect itself going forward engaged
in aggressive
forceful expansion with the goal of
uniting organics under one
empire the prothean empire but protheans
weren't just conquerors
they also cultivated life and influenced
evolution
ultimately it was for their benefit but
there was a hint of benevolence to them
specifically the protheans took an
interest in nurturing fledgling species
that showed potential they would
intervene to force an acceleration of
that development and realize that
potential and they'd eventually invite
these species to join the prothean
empire in addition to humans the asari
hana turian quarian and salerians were
subject to this cultivation of species
the prothean empire and its efforts to
fortify against machine forces seeking
to wipe out organics was put to the test
when the reapers invaded
unlike the machines they faced in the
metacon war the reapers were far more
advanced and
unbeknown to them the tool of their
destruction was also the sea of the
prothean
empire in shepard's cycle the citadel a
space station that serves as the
political and cultural capital of all
space-faring life-forms is believed to
have been created by the protheans
however this isn't the case the
protheans were the last species to use
it and
in actual fact the citadel was created
by the reapers
left drifting in space for intelligent
life forms to discover
to build their civilizations around and
to house information on
all the important species of the
galaxies the citadel was
in fact an inactive mass effect relay
connected to dark space
an open door for the reapers to journey
through when the time came to raise the
galaxy of life
and when the reapers emerged the
prothean empire was crippled in an
instant
the mass effect relays were rendered
inoperable and with all the data stored
in the citadel the reapers were able to
identify the location of all prothean
worlds and begin harvesting them
cut off from each other the prothean
civilizations failed to defend
themselves
with no other choice the prothean war
strategy became one of
attrition they fought system by system
planet by planet
city by city they sacrificed entire
worlds to be harvested by the reapers so
they could buy
enough time to fall back and regroup for
another futile attack
as they did so the reapers indoctrinated
and enslaved protheans they came into
contact with
bolstering their own forces pitting
prothean against prothean and placing
sleeper agents amongst their enemy
the reapers architected the downfall of
the protheans before they even took to
the stars
but the protheans also contribute to it
in a significant way
in the end the cosmic imperative played
a key part in the destruction of their
species
as all races became prothean they
conformed to one doctrine
one mindset one culture one perspective
one strategy such was the way of the
prothean assimilation of culture and
creed the reapers exploited this
rigidity and the protheans could not
adapt to fight back
and survive instead the subservient
races became divided
confused and easy prey but true to the
intelligence that made them the dominant
species in the milky way the protheans
showed foresight and took actions that
would break the cycle for a future
civilization
as the reapers carved a path through the
galaxy the proteins ceased the
development of primitive species in
hopes that the reapers would see no
value in harvesting them
the hope was some protheans would
survive and they would lead these
species
in a future cycle in the centuries the
battle against the reapers took place
the proteins managed to recapture the
citadel they moved it close to a planet
called i4 on which they had discovered
plans for something called the crucible
like the inusanan's mass effect
technology that propelled prothean
civilization
forward the crucible was a noah
fortuitous discovery that would be the
lifeline of a future civilization
designed by the extinct rockfeli species
the plans revealed that the citadel
would be required to wield the crucible
as a weapon
against the reapers the protheans would
never see victory as the crucible could
not be completed before the reapers
finished harvesting the protheans
stripping their worlds of resources
and erasing their presence javik an
experienced soldier and the prothean
avatar for vengeance along with others
were to be hidden in a bunker on eden
prime and placed in stasis to outlast
the cult
javik was to command one million
surviving protheans and lead them
along with the evolved species of a new
cycle in a battle
against the reapers you will be the
voice of our people
i will be more than that however
indoctrinated protheans revealed the
location of the bunker to the reapers
and their neutron purge needed to clear
the bunker impacted the automatic
reactivation of the stasis pods
since javik's survival was imperative he
needed to be kept alive until discovered
by people in a new cycle
this meant that power would be diverted
from the other pods
to his in order to give him the best
chance
in commander shepard's cycle javik
emerges as the last voice of the
protheans
a species that held dominion over entire
galaxy that was brought to its knees by
the reapers
that was unable to defend itself because
of its narrow view of the value of
others
but that ultimately shaped what future
generations needed to give them hope for
a better future
and the last thing the reapers hear
before they die will be the last voice
of the protheans
sending them to their grave hey everyone
timor here thank you so much for
watching this episode of mass effect law
all about the protheans a fascinating
species that we get so little to see
in the games we do get javik though and
he is one of my favorite characters in
the entire franchise
if you're as excited for the legendary
edition as we
are make sure to subscribe to gamespot
we've got a whole lot of videos
in production that is gonna wet your
appetite and get you
nice and warm and excited for mass
effect for when it is
available we're gonna have plenty more
lore videos too
so keep it locked in the meantime you
can find me on twitter at tomorrow h
come and tell me your favorite javik
quotes mine's the one
about staring contests they can go on
for hours when you've got four
eyes
[Music]
you